Louis Leakey sent me to Gombe because he
believed that an understanding of
chimpanzees in the wild would help him
to better guess how our Stone Age
ancestors may have behaved
it had long been thought that we were
the only creatures on earth that used
and made tools man the toolmaker is how
we were defined and here was David
Greybeard
using a tool it was hard for me to
believe what I'd seen few days later
and watched spellbound attempt set off
to a termite mom picked a smaller heat
week and stripped it of its leaves that
was object modification the crude
beginning of tool-making
it had never been seen before
[Music]
[Applause]
when I telegram the news to Louis Leakey
he responded that we must now redefined
man or accept chimpanzees as human my
observations that Gandhi would challenge
human uniqueness and whenever that
happens there is always a violent uproar
there were some who tried to discredit
my observations because I was a young
untrained girl and should therefore be
disregarded the result of it all however
was that Louis was able to obtain a
grant from the National Geographic
Society to continue my study in addition
they would be sending out the
photographer document the chimpanzees
[Music]
you